let's see if we can add nine point zero
eight seven to fifteen point three one
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to do it on your own so I'm
assuming you have tried to do it on your
own and now let's see how we could
actually tackle this now one thing I
want to point out some of you all might
see these numbers all lined up and
immediately want to say hey 7 plus 1 is
8 and 8 plus 3 is 11 carry the 1 etc etc
and if you did that you would be making
a mistake because you see right over
here these decimals aren't lined up here
you if you did that you would be adding
the 7 thousand to 100's you would be
adding 0 tenths to 5 ones you would be
adding 9 to 1 tens or essentially this
is a 10 right over here so the places
would be all mixed up so what you need
to do is actually align the decimals so
that your place values are aligned so
what you want to do is you want to align
things up so we could write nine point
zero eight seven and then we want to
align the decimal so let's align the
decimal this is what has to match up and
this is going to be 15 point three one
and this should hopefully make sense to
you as well this is 9 point something
plus 15 point something so it's going to
be if you add a nine to 15 you get it'll
be 24 point something give or take a
little bit so when you see that here
that here you have a nine plus the 15 so
you've lined up the appropriate place
values and now we are ready we are ready
to add it's a good idea to start with
the smallest place value so if you have
any extra at a certain place you can
bring in to some you could bring
something into the next place value so
here you say seven plus well I know this
is 7 thousandths it's in the thousands
place and you might want to say well
what do I add it to there's no
thousandths right over here and you're
right there are no thousand so we could
literally write 0 thousandths so 7
thousandths plus 0 thousandths is seven
thousand eight hundred plus one
hundredths is nine hundredths 0 plus 0
tenths plus three tenths is three tenths
we got our decimal then you have nine
one plus 5 ones is 14 ones well 14 ones
is the same thing as four ones and one
10 so we'll carry that one right over
there this is just one 10 plus four ones
is 14 and so then finally you have one
10 plus another 10 is 2 so we get 24
point three nine seven